So back in the spring, we put a note on the web that said
if you would like to build something that might be the DPLA, just start,
tell us by June 15 that you want to do it with a letter of intent, and by September 1,
send it to the Steering Committee, your results.
It can be big or small and code or not code,
but the basic idea is to give us a glimpse of what this might be
and we will have a review panel of people
without any conflict of interest among the sprinters, and then we'll invite
the most promising to present at the National Archives.
So we're going to have six presentations that are sort of "full" presentations
Each group will speak for no more than seven minutes
and then about seven minutes of discussion with each one,
and then our review panel also chose three for "lightning round" presentations.
They'll go five minutes each in a series, and then we'll have commentary for them after that.
I want to thank the blue-ribbon review panel, they were wonderful
they came to Cambridge after doing a ton of homework
after reviewing 48 submissions that were unbelievably great
and rich and spent time locked in a conference room
and came out with recommendations that are fantastic.
They were John Weiss, Patsy Baudoin, Michael Santangelo, Maeve Clark, Eli Neiburger, Laura DeBonis, David Rumsey, and Jessamyn West,
and I'd like to have a round of applause for the volunteer group.
All right, so the first of the groups is one those referenced earlier,
digital collaboration for America's national collections,
representing three organizations that have worked collaboratively together -
The Smithsonian, the National Archives, and the Library of Congress
Martin Kalfatovic, Chin Sing Yun, and Pam Wright are here to present, so over to you guys.
The main purpose of our Beta Sprint entry was to show
that these three large institutions that could collaborate together
and I think that is the proof of concept that we did so
everything else is the special sauce.
We've heard already some of the statistics of our different collections
and what we primarily did in this case was using some records from each of the three institutions
and we put them into the Smithsonian's Collections Search Project that Chin Sing will talk about in a minute.
Primarily to show how the different data from libraries,
archives, and museums could interact in one large
data system and provide different types of access to the data.
So with that I will turn it over to Chin Sing who will talk about how we did this
and then you can ask questions about the details.
I think Mark has aluded to the fact that we're using the existing
Smithsonian Collections Search Center and extending it to this Beta Sprint project,
to see how things turned out and the three major organizations participating
and we have all sorts of interesting materials and we wanted to make sure that
this is something that we could use not only for one institution, but for many.
We started this project by making sure that we have a
dynamic extendable metadata model
and this is something the Smithsonian has spent time
reviewing national standards
and looking for commonalities
and looking for specialties,
anything from standard printed materials to scientific specimens,
the mosquitos and little bugs and making sure taxonomy information is properly addressed,
so therefore, looking over the national standards,
and various cataloging standards assuring the metadata covers all the commonalities.
And this is one of the examples, a tiny snippet of what the metadata model looks like
and in this particular section addresses the geographical location of the tags.
For example, a photograph can be taken at a location and we can have latitude and longitude information
which can be used for searching purposes -
A bug can be collected at a particular location, and this can help
scientists track the migration patterns of the bug or birds or a whale or anything like that.
So this is just a snippet of what the metadata looks like.
Obviously, we have cooperation from the three organization
- and this shows the 11 records from the National Archives
and this is under a time constraint so we did data menus converstion
from the National Archives and the Library of Congress.
The nothing else has changed as a result of it to make everything a separate
and not independent thoughts floating around, we went in to work together so that high-level
architecture, basically includes,
as you can see on the bottom various independent sources
for specialized databases and focus
and each of the organizations all have similar kinds of
challenges but the goal and help end up doing,
does allow the metadata model to be the guide
and standardize the data format
and it is suggested into a central index search index
or temporary metadata and this is not permanent,
just for indexing sake
and then coupling with the concept,
we allow several web services to , for example,
to use the data.
For example, metadata delivery services focusing on searching
and retrieval of potential information.
On the right side of the screen you see an indexed image delivery service
and that is for the purpose of doing manipulation of
indexes and images, assuming and resizing and finally,
attacking services that allow -- for tagging services that allow public input
and allow people to tag our materials Brigadier with these services,
we allow people to start developing their own web
interface and by no means is this a single interface or architecture.
I don't have a whole lot of time this is a high-level
system architecture and processing goes through,
starting from the bottom up,
you will see all of the databases
and it gets adjusted its volume index and then, between,
you'd see a box go up and down, the Aeros, it's preprocessing stage
and that is where we do extensive scrubbing of data, standardization,
make sure the data coming from different sources actually conforms to different standards
and then leverage that into our master index
and it replicates a number of slaves to handle high-level traffic at this point,
the data has no particular phase until some web applications start to have it.
You see the red dotted line that educates the firewall and outside of the firewall is the number of applications
that can be developed and I will end they are for questions.
-- I will end there for questions. [Applause]
Hello. My name is TJ freight my question is how often,
and the final implementation,
how often would the indexing happen?
Would it be one time per record or would it be,
updated as they might change?
The answer is,
at different intervals for different organizations,
for the Library of Congress, so far,
we have done one time but I am sure we can negotiate a
refreshing schedule for four internal Smithsonian,
they range from daily updates to weekly updates to
monthly updates to quarterly update Center depends on how
often the data is refreshed and updated
and how often the organization contributes to the field that they can handle
and the system is built in such a way that it is
culminating all levels of frequency. Question.
-- Good question.
Jerry Simmons, national archives,
the team lead for authority cataloging and I'm interested in how you got this data to interact rate
The data, the system part is not difficult to build ultimately,
what really grew everything together
and how they start interacting is really through the
metadata themselves. And I think that the catalogers, professional catalogers,
that is what we need to thank them for.
The data is obviously,
this urbanization has to be dealing with all views of the
internal standards if not the national standards we have
the benefit of that advantage of the architecture thesaurus, subject headings,
all of these terms are important and what we talk
and we mentioned there is a lot of scrubbing process,
it really is to standardize terms, oftentimes,
simply miss spellings that oftentimes we just match those
terms up we have the database and we have right now,
probably 50,000 lines of exceptions that process through
to scrub the data to make it standardized rate was the data to standardize,
the records actually start interacting with each other.
Jerry McGann University of Virginia.
Can you speak to the kind of traffic you could come to
expect him to the alliance of scaling in the kind of traffic you can expect?
The next that is a hard question to answer because I
don't have the number on hand however,
the surf Center which is a main website that retrieves content from the end-users,
we have in the neighborhood of 25,000 unique visitors per
month however, the system is not built for one interface.
We have web applications using data
and we also have individual web applications using the data.
We have to level applications each with a different focus
and I don't have statistics but I know that a majority of
the traffic actually comes from the southern application
of the LeMay one really provided. In other words,
if some DPL -- DPLA
and they want to write the application history to tell
the story of their town or Poulter,
they can draw on  a lot of materials from other
organizations and one example I would point out,
since I'm -- the Sony
and is a well-known American injury this -- Museum American Indian Museum
and have a collection of surprise they found out the
national history Museum has anthropology department which
has a tremendous amount of questions that we find extremely supplemental and useful
and also there is a national anthropological archives
that the Smithsonian has that has even more cultural
and language materials that they find useful.
So all of these pleasant surprises before we did not realize that now, --
Please join me in thanking Chin Sing.